we've got a major development to report
in the Ohio train derailment
investigators now say the accident was
preventable and that there were several
sign and signs warning signs before the
crash in East Palestine Ohio which
spilled toxic chemicals into the area
train operator Norfolk Southern says its
crew acted properly and pledged to
continue cooperating this comes as
Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge visited East Palestine after
facing weeks of criticism for his
absence Roxanna saberi has the latest
Secretary of Transportation Pete
budajesh acknowledged the criticism he's
received in recent weeks I'm here for
the work and not for the Politics as he
visited the scene of the toxic train
derailment in East Palestine well first
of all I want them to know they're not
alone that uh before during and after
the uh national attention they're going
to have support they're going to have
support from us when it comes to holding
Norfolk Southern accountable they're
going to have support from the EPA when
it comes to making sure they get
accurate information about the safety of
their air water and soil
as trains continued to pass through this
small town a preliminary NTSB report
shows investigators are focusing on an
overheated wheel bearing on the Train's
23rd car according to the report defect
detectors placed along the tracks
recorded three separate increased
temperature readings before the disaster
the first 38 degrees above the outside
temperature then 10 miles later 103
degrees and finally 253 degrees above
the critical threshold setting off an
alarm on the train the NTSB says that's
when the crew applied the brakes as
mandated but the bearing failed and 38
cars derailed problems need to be
identified early so something
catastrophic like this
does not occur again I didn't even know
those chemicals involved until
two days later maybe Eric Whiting an
East Palestine resident for 12 years
lives only around 30 yards from the
train tracks no value is in the home
anymore and maybe that value will come
back but it'll be years before even the
stigma of the town is lifted he says
Norfolk Southern should consider buying
out homes like his
for CBS mornings I'm Roxanna saberi